[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 los más
vulnerables un programa sobre cómo esta
pandemia la han atravesado los cientos
de millones de personas que ya vivían en
situaciones de pobreza de marginalidad
de hacinamiento o se veían obligadas a
migrar o eran víctimas de guerras y
conflictos mi nombre es andrés suárez
jaramillo
millones de personas de la clase media
de américa latina- están transitando
hacia la pobreza por cuenta de la
pandemia de kobe 19 así lo exponen
varias organizaciones como la onu la
cepal y la oit y oxfam las cifras son
alarmantes de los 650 millones de
personas que viven en latinoamérica 52
millones dejarían la clase media para
entrar en la clase baja esto se explica
por una contracción regional del 9 por
ciento en la economía que habría dejado
sin empleo a 40 millones de individuos
las cifras se enmarcan en el hecho de
que 5 de los 10 principales países del
mundo con kobe 19 se encuentran en
nuestro continente a continuación el
informe
después del estancamiento económico que
américa latina sufrió en 1980 la clase
media logró emerger solo hasta la década
del 2000 gracias a un auge en la
comercialización de materias primas pero
de acuerdo con expertos de la cepal la
economía latinoamericana es frágil por
dos factores su dependencia de sectores
de baja productividad como la minería y
la agricultura y la corrupción de sus
gobiernos que impiden que los impuestos
sean repartidos de manera justa a favor
de la población cuál es el resultado
después de esta pandemia pues la verdad
que haber más pobreza más desigualdad
más hambre y ojalá no haya más enojo
porque creo que ese es otro elemento
importante había ya un desencanto en la
región como telón de fondo que venía
antes de la pandemia yo ya reclamando
factores de igualdad muy importantes en
varios países de la región y quizás esto
tenga algún cierto riesgo de agudizarse
junto a la pandemia de coronavirus
varios países han sufrido remezones
internos en sus economías en venezuela
la crisis que comenzó en 2012
la hiperinflación a más de 10 millones
por ciento en 2019 de acuerdo con el fm
y provocó la migración de cerca de 6
millones de venezolanos según la onu
en chile la recesión está reviviendo la
ira que marcó las violentas protestas de
finales de 2019 y en perú el congreso
intentó destituir al presidente martín
vizcarra en parte por la falta de apoyo
a las pequeñas empresas ya los
independientes el momento más duro fue
el darme cuenta de que la mensualidad de
mi hijo no la podía pagar yo te hago el
esfuerzo de pagarle un colegio privado
con todo el esfuerzo pero no se podía
pagar el pensar que te cambiarla a un
colegio estatal ese cambio en no poder
solventar los gastos en la comida o los
juegos de los servicios de acuerdo con
la comisión económica de la onu para
américa latina cerca de 27 millones de
negocios lo que representa el 20 por
ciento de las compañías de la región
cerrarán a causa de la pandemia una
proyección que se nutre con la realidad
que 34 millones de personas ya han
perdido sus trabajos en el 2020
los alimentos han catapultado
y eso es lo que me ayuda a los dólares
la onu advierte que la contracción de
latinoamérica será la más grande del
mundo con 9 por ciento en consecuencia
oxfam cifra en 52 millones las personas
que entrarán en la lista de pobreza
donde se vive con menos de 2 dólares al
día un retroceso de más de 15 años que
además de golpear a la clase media
afecta en particular a las mujeres ya
los grupos indígenas
precisamente una de las tribus más
afectadas por el cob y 19 y por la
recesión económica son los bajar a los
guardianes de los bosques en brasil
después de meses de pedir ayudas
sanitarias el estado envió decenas de
profesionales de la salud para tratar la
pandemia en sus territorios aunque ésta
no es la única amenaza que pone en jaque
a la comunidad indígena más grande del
brasil los detalles los tiene maría
clara calle
tres semanas internados en la amazonía
de brasil así estuvo este equipo clínico
que ascendió a los indígenas guajará
afectados por el cob y 19 en la región
de marina o en el noreste del país los
bajará son conocidos como los guardianes
del bosque que lo protegen de las talas
ilegales además de ser una de las tribus
más grandes de brasil también es una de
las más golpeadas por la pandemia
ellos llevaban meses pidiéndole al
estado que les practicará pruebas de
kobe 19 y que no sólo atendiera a
quienes viven en las reservas
el ministerio de defensa respondió
enviando un convoy de profesionales de
la salud que hizo más de 37.000
controles y repartido 39 toneladas de
medicamentos equipos de vídeo protección
y comida
donde hacemos esto para brindar atención
médica a los pueblos indígenas de todo
mar and out sin importar de qué grupo
étnico sean migrantes estamos llevando a
todo el equipo multidisciplinario de
médicos enfermeras farmacéuticos
nutricionistas y funcionarios de salud
para indígenas a las aldeas para que
podamos trabajar para combatir el cubil
19 y otras patologías que se detuvieron
debido a la utilización dentro del
equipo de profesionales también llegaron
ginecólogos y veterinarios con la
intención de atender otras enfermedades
diferentes al cob y 19 pero el virus
sigue en el centro de las preocupaciones
la articulación de pueblos indígenas una
organización de brasil dice que más de
35 mil miembros de las tribus del país
se han infectado una cifra que es alta
en comparación con el contagio del resto
de los brasileños pues sólo hay cerca de
800 mil indirectos
es por eso que los bajarás piden que la
atención se mantenga
precisa que necesitamos más atención en
las comunidades ligeras con todo lo que
está sucediendo
necesitamos más atención y la
sensibilidad de toda la humanidad para
atender a los pueblos en algunas de toda
la humanidad que vamos a este barco de
bendición a la sensibilidad que pide
taiwán a jara no es sólo frente al kobe
19 la defensa de la naturaleza le ha
traído amenazas a esta comunidad
el consejo misionero indígena asegura
por ejemplo que la violencia contra los
guajará ha aumentado por los madereros
ilegales que se quieren apropiar de su
territorio y es por todo esto que
prenden las alarmas pues la pandemia no
es el único riesgo
viajemos a áfrica en nigeria una mujer
empresaria está decidida a bajar el
nivel de importaciones de repuestos de
vehículos desde que montó su negocio en
2013 con cerca de 1.300 dólares sus
ventas han incrementado al punto de
vender más de 60 mil repuestos al año su
trabajo ha logrado que varios
compradores nigerianos inviertan
localmente en lugar de comprar a
mercados extranjeros normalmente en
nigeria se importan los repuestos de las
tradicionales motos tuk-tuk desde china
pero humacao coche ha ayudado con su
empresa a producir made y nigeria además
su marca ha empleado a cinco mujeres con
lo cual busca reducir la brecha de
género en la industria automotriz de
nigeria dominada desde siempre por los
hombres según cantó water manga una
mujer puede hacer lo que un hombre puede
hacer e incluso lo puede hacer mejor
durante mucho tiempo ha sido una mujer
que hace el trabajo fuerte y la gente
que viene queda asombrada y sorprendida
de ver a una mujer haciendo esto yo lo
disfruto y es que amo lo que hago
trasladémonos ahora a la región del
cáucaso en europa del este mientras
armenia y azerbaiyán siguen en conflicto
por el territorio de nagorno karabaj
cientos de ciudadanos en la capital
armenia decidieron unir sus fuerzas para
apoyar a los más afectados
su intención es recolectar mercados y
ropa para enviar a quienes todavía no se
han desplazado y siguen en medio de los
bombardeos otros armenios optaron por
rezar para que los enfrentamientos
acaben pronto maría clara calle nos
cuenta que están haciendo los mismos
ciudadanos frente a esta crisis
decenas de cajas se apilan en las calles
de global talar medio los habitantes de
múltiples barrios se unieron para
recolectar mercados y enviarlos a
nagorno karabaj aunque más de la mitad
de los pobladores de este territorio se
tuvieron que desplazar por los
enfrentamientos entre armenia y
azerbaiyán cerca de 70 mil personas
siguen viviendo en medio de los
bombardeos y su comida es cada vez más
escasa
por eso desde ereván quieren ayudar a
los armenios de cara bajo el principio
comenzamos con amigos y conocidos
traíamos las mercancías nosotros mismos
las enviamos y luego se hizo en mayor
escala
una persona ciudadanos la gente que
pasaba todos los armenios que estaban
juntos empezaron a ayudar y también
organizamos el transporte en las
brigadas humanitarias no sólo importa el
alimento que lleve también son claves
los voluntarios y estos pueden ser de
todas las ciudades ya estos montes a
cabo ahora el esto ayuda a arreglar las
cosas otras personas de buena voluntad
que quieren ayudar con la comida y la
ropa lo traen aquí pero manos
otros habitantes de ereván prefieren
apegarse a la religión desde la iglesia
de sant sarquís una de las más
importantes del catolicismo ortodoxo de
armenia decenas de fieles prenden velas
por los que consideran sus compatriotas
y también por los combatientes de
azerbaiyán su único deseo es que el
conflicto acabe pronto
solemos venir pero en estos días con más
frecuencia rezamos por nuestros hijos
por la paz en el país
los soldados a series también tienen
madres y padres que esta guerra termine
lo antes posible
[Música]
a los ruegos y las ayudas humanitarias
se unen las fuerzas de los pobladores de
coris esta ciudad armenia es la más
cercana a narco no cara baja por lo que
se ha convertido en el primer refugio de
los civiles que huyen de las
confrontaciones
desde los primeros bombardeos el 27 de
septiembre los habitantes de goris
comenzaron a recibir a los desplazados y
luego organizaron más sus esfuerzos
ahora el ayuntamiento es el centro de
acopio de la ropa y el mercado que
recolectan por todas las ciudadanos y
muchas veces también es un refugio así
es como los armenios están respondiendo
a la oleada de personas que huyen de
nargó no cara baja
este es el panorama de los más
vulnerables de esta semana en el mundo
ante el coronavirus organismos
internacionales y gobiernos están
anunciando paquetes de ayuda pero son
miles de millones las personas que
enfrentan esta pandemia en frágiles
condiciones y el alivio sólo es relativo
gracias por seguirnos recuerden que más
información la pueden encontrar en
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]